hallo liebe zuschauer und herzlich
willkommen zurück bei easyjet heute
wieder bei klaus im haus erinnert euch
sicher episode nummer 92 waren wir schon
mal hier und haben von alkohol für euch
gekocht die episode hieß klaus kocht und
wir haben euch damals aufgerufen
mal zu sagen was als nächstes kommen
sollen und ganz viele von euch haben
schnitzel gewollt und heute sind wir
zurück und machen eine schlüsselpartie
da mal ein schnitzel party nicht nur zu
zweit macht haben wir noch den martin
dazu eingeladen und npd willkommen
klaus bis heute der clean schiff martino
peter werden kommen so rita aus heute ja
und wir fangen mal an mit den zutaten
also wir machen heute ja zwei sachen zum
einen schnitzel und zum anderen machen
wir einen leckeren kartoffelsalat für
die schnitzel brauchen wir zunächst
natürlich fleisch wir haben jetzt viel
schweinefleisch man kann aber genauso
gut jedes andere fleisch nehmen zum
beispiel vom kalb oder auch vom hähnchen
man braucht man braucht paniermehl und
man braucht normales mail
die pilze kommen später noch dazu weil
wir ein schnitzel mit pilzen machen
wollen was braucht man für den salat
peter ja da wäre ganz frische gurken vom
rewe paprikaschoten mayonnaise ganz
wichtig dann frische äpfel aus dem
eigenen garten hier kartoffeln und
paprika wir machen es heute nämlich so
dass ich heute keinen finger rühren
werde sondern diese beiden herren hier
werden heute kochen und ich schaue nur
über die schulter ob sie auch alles
richtig machen du bist für die gesamte
organisation zuständig und wirst auch
gute laune
die gute laune und du wirst am ende als
erstes essen klaus ist los mit 1 womit
fangen an
zunächst einmal wie peter jetzt hier die
kartoffeln schälen weil die müssen
erstmal gut durchkochen für den salat
und da das sehr lange braucht fangen wir
damit erstmal andere ich sagen habt ihr
eine tochter
dann kann ich dir schon mal einen topf
in der küche selbstverständlich und
carina das schätze ich sagt klaus ja der
erste lacher aus dem publikum war da wir
haben heute live publikum hier werden
wir gleich mal einblenden
und das hört sich so an klaus
dass er stets organisiert auftritte
meinte der martin kann auch schon was
machen also erstmal sollte peter die
schale nicht so dick abschneiden der
markt schon mal machen weil wir haben
noch mehr sachen zu schnippeln wir haben
wie zum beispiel die äpfel die paprika
oder auch die gurken wir müssen alle
noch klein geschnitten werden ich habe
ihn auch schon ein messer mitgebracht
und ein brettchen und damit kann man
auch anfang frage vorweg habt euch ja
nicht die hände gewaschen
ich werde jetzt versuchen diese schale
in einer linie abzustellen ich weiß
nicht ob es mir gelingt ich bin schon
unglaublich gespannt eine oper hat mir
das mal früher beigebracht ich habe das
auch ein oder zweimal geschafft
natürlich war mein scheller wesentlich
schärfer ist dieses gerät natürlich sind
sie dann so unspektakuläre sidekicks die
einfach das programm wahnsinnig in die
länge ziehen redewendung mal passend zu
anmerken und zwar das passte zu martin
wenn man nicht schwimmen kann liegt an
der badehose
aber es scheint zu funktionieren
trotz des schäfers ja klaus wie schneide
ich dann den apfel klaus wir haben jetzt
hier schon mehrere minuten sind die
beiden schon so lange ich würde gerne
wissen so ein erstes kleines resümee wie
schlagen sich die beiden ganz gut also
ich bin also was ich ganz toll findet
wir haben auch kein blut also noch hat
sich keiner verletzt was bei den beiden
schon echt ein wunder ist ja wir sagen
weiter so jungs ne na.de kartoffeln sind
geschält die äpfel sind geschnitten
jetzt fangen uns natürlich wie es
weitergeht kraus ja kann ich ihnen sagen
also einmal martin vorsichtig das nicht
runterfällt
danach kannst du direkt weitermachen mit
den gurken würde ich sagen und der peter
der müsste die kartoffeln mal auf dem
herd stellen ist allerdings ein bisschen
zu viel wasser drin das abschließen
salz haben wir raus müssen
viele leute tun zu wenig salz ins wasser
auch bei nudeln
dadurch wird al dente wir haben ja hier
wie schnitzel die haben wir jetzt
einfach im supermarkt so gekauft was wir
machen würden ist wie würden sie noch
ein wenig flach klopfen mit dem
fleischklopfer wofür macht man das hab
ich mich schon immer gefragt
ich habe keine ahnung vielleicht damit
das schön dünn wird david peter
das sind hier guten aus dem
wunderschönen spreewald auch sogenannte
spreewaldgurken oder saure gurken es
eine besondere kleine gurken art die
wird dann in essig eingelegt und wird
dann schön wackelig complete dann kommt
da auch manchmal ein bisschen saft raus
ein gutes gefühl wird es auch machen ja
danke
man sieht es ist auf jeden fall schon
flacher und größer von der fläche her
geworden
das publikum schläft fast 1
dann erzähl doch mal ein witz kari hallo
wasser peter kommst du zu recht
ich bin so was kann ich als sechster
mann du kannst hier weiter klopfen peter
du siehst das ist gar nicht so schwer
wisst ihr nicht dass gleich knüpfen ja
ich weiss nicht also mit mehr esprit
könnte peter schon machen
peter bereitet gerade die panade vor
damit wir gleich panieren können ein
schnitzel wird der plan paniert dafür
haben wir einmal paniermehl normales
mail und rohe eier
die zerschlagen sind wir sehen jetzt
live wie klaus diese sechs schnitzel
paniert klaus beschreibt uns doch bitte
was du machst
ich nehme das schnitzel isst kommt erst
einmal in das mail dass ein bisschen
mehr an hängen bleibt dann geht mit
samurai gezogen so und am ende noch mal
in pannier mit angedrückt dass möglichst
viel über alpha nehme ein kleben bleibt
und dann war's das schon
peter hast du aufgepasst ich habe
aufgepasst kannst du jetzt weitermachen
peter wir sind die kartoffeln schon
durch vielfalt unter vom herd yamaha
team das hast du jetzt genutzt ich habe
jetzt hier die zutaten für sing alle
zusammen gekippt und schlat oft ein
bisschen sämig und jetzt werde ich das
ganze einmal den peter zum probieren
geben so liebe ist zuschauer das warten
hat sich gelohnt es geht jetzt los
das schnitzel schnell raus wir haben wir
fahren mit ganz heißen richtig ist das
richtig heißes ich freue mich gelernt
habe auch es muss viel hilft viel
und ihr seht schon wie es anfängt hier
zu frittieren
so richtig schwimmen öl richtig ist es
wichtig spiel mit öl
damit ist auch nicht schön kross wird
die ärzte sagen weißt du was mir gerade
auffällt klaus ich habe mein leben leben
lang schnitzel immer falsch gemacht
wieso ich habe da immer ganz wenig fett
reingetan dann sind die mal angebracht
ja da ist ja etwas gelernt hab ich
wieder was gelernt kann sein dass tv
geworden dass martin das kann von
ordentlich zu schneiden man stehe jetzt
nur noch mit dem messer in der in der
schüssel rum ist es korrekt
ich hab mir einfach eine effizientere
technik entdeckt denn ich bin schon
fertig ja jetzt kommt das dressing über
den salat
dann ist auch schon fertig und ich würde
sagen dass super gewinnt aus es auch so
dass heute ein kleiner traum wahr wird
für peter wollte schon immer meinen ist
klaus kreise kleiner traum es ist ein
großer traum und ich versuche immer noch
durchzusetzen dass wir mal nur eine
folge mit mir und klaus in einer fremden
stadt ja aber das scheitert er irgendwie
angesehene habe ich gehört
nee gar nicht da ist auch einfach mal
ein bisschen fanfiction gefragt schreibt
uns einfach mal was ihr gerne mal sehen
will was fehler und klaus zusammen
machen
guck mal da ruft sie an mir sitzen jetzt
hier und warten auf die schnitzel um die
schnitzel klaus wie die echten deutschen
sitzen wir natürlich nicht zusammen beim
essen also wir sind nun schon zusammen
aber wir gucken fußball gerade läuft
deutschland polen was für ein glück hast
ein tierisch und appetit vor allen
dingen wie steht's denn gerade peter 2 1
für deutschland
doch klaus
ja liebe zuschauer das haus nämlich
schon mit unserer heutigen episode ihr
seht ihr schnitzel sind fertig danke
schön peter der kartoffelsalat wird sehr
wird und wir haben uns gerade überlegt
ohne klaus zu fragen haben wir uns
überlegt dass wir das jetzt öfter machen
wollen wir sind schon sowieso eine
familie zusammengewachsen
die easy german familie weder martin
glaus und der ice und unser publikum
dass unbeteiligte gut sitzt wir möchten
das gerne erstmal machen und ihr könnt
ihr uns natürlich auch ein paar
vorschläge schicken was wir machen
sollen wir noch mal kochen und wenn ja
was soll man vielleicht mal was
gemeinsam unternehmen
fallschirmspringer mal darauf hinweisen
dass er sehr gerne fallschirmspringen
möchte wenn ihr das auch möchte dann
schreibt uns mal dann filmen wie beim
fallschirmspringen
guten appetit
ja ich würde sagen guten appetit liebe
leute genießt das leckere essen und ihr
sagt uns mal was wir als nächstes kommen
sollen dann zeigen wir euch weitere
deutsche gerichte bei klaus im haus
klaus nimmst uns gerne auf danke fürs
zuschauen werden euch hat es gefallen
ihr könnt ihr zuhause aus ihrem
anschluss schnitzel ausprobieren und wir
sehen uns nächste woche wieder bei easy
germany